le canada est le deuxième meilleur pays
du monde après la suisse selon un
nouveau rapport américain pour établir
le palmarès best countries will power
plus de vingt mille personnes ont été
interrogées partout dans le monde sur
leur perception sur 80 pays en fonction
de 75 critères différents hommes
l'économie l'environnement la
technologie la culture où le climat
social par exemple la suisse est
considéré le meilleur pays au monde mais
canada des phases cette année le japon
pour se loger au deuxième rang le canada
se démarque par sa stabilité politique
son marché de l'emploi la sécurité du
système de santé et la qualité de
l'éducation
au chapitre de la qualité de vie le
canada arrive même premier pour une
cinquième année le canada obtient aussi
une note parfaite pour ses pratiques
commerciales et le respect du droit des
citoyens
[Musique]